i don't know if you
remember much of this hue but there was
there was a casting kerfuffle
on who to cast for hannibal lecter and
there was
a a difference of opinion on
what a a television network a
traditional television network would
want as a leading man and what
we would want as a
an actor playing hannibal lecter um
to personify that character and i think
the network wanted somebody that was
much more poppy
much more mainstream uh
much more american i think in in some
ways
and uh but that was just them thinking
about like okay how do we get the
biggest audience
for our television show we have to cast
john cusack as hannibal lecter and
everybody will tune in
because won't that be surprising that
was my face
and i was like like well let's
go ahead make an offer um so there was
some resistance to mass mickelson
because he was european
because he was somebody that you could
look at and say like yeah i buy that he
eats people
and you know that there was an
interesting kind of
we were dealing with a death a very
american
uh network that wanted a very american
actor to sell to american audiences
and i and all the creatives on the show
wanted somebody who was the best person
for the role and
because we didn't have that that kind of
uh john cusack hugh grant
um these are some of the names that the
network really wanted
uh in the role that felt like it was
more about selling the movie than
making the the most authentic movie and
that's not to say that neither of those
things
are invalid uh but because we cast mass
and because it was sort of
a uh it was an interesting dance because
i would say mass mickelson that said no
how about hugh grant i'm like great make
an offer he's gonna say no he would make
an offer he'd say no and they'd be like
what about maz nicholson they're like
well how about john cusack and like
great make an offer he's going to say no
then make an offer he'd say no i'd say
what about as mickelson
and that was like that carousel went
around for i think three or four months
after we had cast hue
it like it was going on for a while um
and finally i just said like maz is the
guy that's the guy that i see
in the role and i have to write it and i
have to
champion it i have to understand it and
and jennifer sulky at nbc
bless her heart was like okay like
that's your guy
and i believe you and i trust you and
i'm excited about the vision for the
show
but for the other sort of marketing
folks they were like oh this show isn't
going to break
through for us they sort of gave up on
it a little bit
because we were casting a european
guy as the face of that they wanted to
be much more
accessible uh and i felt that they were
they were right for their reasons but
wrong for my reasons
and so the gift of that the gift of
casting mattis mickelson is that their
investment in the show
uh became dramatically decreased and so
that allowed us to do a lot of things
that we wouldn't have been able to do
if they were saying like no this show
needs to get 10 million people watching
it every
every every week because then we would
have to
really be tied down to certain
parameters of storytelling that we're
going to
mesh with a a mainstream audience
so mass was the gift that allowed
us to tell the story the way that we
wanted to tell it
because the network was like well it's
not the person that we wanted and we
don't really see him in this role
and we were like fine just let us make
the show and they were like here and so
you know we didn't get great ratings and
we didn't get great numbers and the
network was
was behind us but they weren't as behind
us as they would have been
if we had cast who they wanted
um but i think in the grand universal
scheme it was the best thing for the
show
a because we got to have mass and human
scenes together and they were electric
and also we got to do things that were
questionable
with the content because they they
we didn't we didn't we weren't we were
no longer expected to
achieve a certain goal i think that if
you would cast someone like cusack let's
arbitrarily throw that name out there um
they might have insisted more on a
procedural
show and less serialized storytelling
they would have insisted on all sorts of
things we wouldn't have got it in a way
with a third of the things that we got
away with
or you know tried to do in our
narratives
just because you know low expectations
are good
you know low expectations will allow
artists to flourish in ways
that when there are higher expectations
and
you know more restrictions because
there's more writing on it for the
network
and that's why they cast james spader
and the blacklist because that they were
like see this is what we wanted to do
that you wouldn't do
and so we're going to do it this is our
show you go do your little show
we'll air it but this is the show that
we really wanted to do
and the moment they cast james spader
and the blacklist
was when they kind of took their
attention away
from what we were doing on hannibal so
it was really about
like oh let them do their weird little
show like we're not paying very
much for it and we're going to bury it
on a thursday night at 10 or a friday
night at 10
and so we only need it to perform this
much
and we performed this match
but right and then we became i suppose a
show that that
meant something different to them in
terms of value because we got good
reviews and because
we we stuck out in a different way in
their roster of shows right and that
that's also a good look and i think it's
something that they were actively
interested in in pursuing right and and
so we fitted into a different part of
the model which was exactly
i think where we wanted to be yes like
i think it's where we where it's where
the universe definitely
placed us so we could maximize what we
wanted to do